Today we uh discuss the most famous
person who has ever lived. There are
about two billion people in the world
today who believe that Jesus is God. And
so a question then is
there have been many famous individuals
in history. Alexand the great, Julius
Caesar, Socrates, Zorahustra,
Homer, but it is Jesus that most people
worship. And the question we will look
at today is why? Okay. So, what I want
to do first is discuss the religion of
Christianity.
And
as you know, I grew up in Canada and I
studied United States. And so my entire
life,
um, Jesus was part of the culture. It
was part of the society. [clears throat]
And
growing up in Canada, not being
Christian, I really didn't understand
Christianity.
I really didn't understand the ideas.
Um so let's go over some of the major
ideas of Christianity. Uh first of all
it's important to remember that there
are many denominations in Christianity.
So there's a lot of disagreements. Okay.
But these are the major ideas that most
Christians agree on. First thing is that
Jesus
is the son of God
and God himself. Okay. And he's king.
Okay. [snorts] This this already is very
confusing.
Um second thing is they believe that
Jesus died for our sins.
So remember that we got kicked out of
the garden of Eden because we disobeyed
God and we ate from the tree of um
knowledge. Okay. So Jesus died for our
sins and so Jesus redeemed us.
Okay. Um the third thing that they
believe is that eventually
Jesus
will return
something called the second coming. He
died, then he was resurrected, then went
to heaven. But eventually he will return
and this will result in the last
judgment
in which all individuals
are judged whether they will reign in
heaven or burn in hell. Okay? He will
bring heaven to earth. And this is where
Christianity is most controversial.
What this says is that if you believe in
Jesus, if you're a Christian,
you will go to heaven.
But if you do not believe in Jesus,
you will burn in hell. And this is and
this goes against all other religious
traditions. Every religious tradition is
basically like be a good person and
that's all you have to do. But
Christianity demands that you must
believe in Jesus or you will burn in
hell. Okay? So in other words,
Christianity is a missionary religion in
which
if you're a Christian, not only do you
believe not only do you must believe in
Jesus, but you must go out and try to
convert other people because if they
don't convert to Christianity during the
last judgment, they will burn in hell.
And that is why Christianity is one of
the most aggressive religions that we
have today. So this is all very strange
and there are a lot of questions in
Christianity and that's why Christianity
also proposes the idea of miracles.
Okay.
How did Jesus die for our sins? Why is
there a second coming? It's all a
miracle. Okay? Meaning don't question
it. Just believe in it. Right? So
Christianity
is a very problematic uh religion. It
raises a lot of questions. Okay. So then
the question then is given all the
confusion around Christianity, why do so
many people believe in Jesus? All right.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to explain to you what we know for sure
about Jesus. This is not um religious
people. It's scholars who spent decades
researching the evidence, looking the
Bible, looking at the archeological
evidence, looking at all the writings of
that period. And this is what we know
for sure about Jesus. Okay. All right.
So, the life of Jesus.
Okay. So, the first thing that we know
is he was born maybe about 4 BCE.
Okay. In a place called Galilee.
I know in the Bible it says he was born
the year zero, but he's actually um born
four years before then. All right,
that's the first thing that we know for
sure. Most people agree on. I'm talking
about like mainstream academics.
Second thing that we agree on is that
his teacher was John the Baptist. And
John the Baptist is what we call an
apocalyptic
preacher. Okay? An apocalyptic preacher
basically says, "I will reveal the
future to you." And the future is that
God is coming and God will destroy the
evil people in the world. So right now
is your opportunity to redeem yourself
from your sins to start a new life
because God is coming and we must
prepare for the return of God. That is
the message of John the Baptist and
Jesus was one of his students, one of
his disciples. But at some point Jesus
started to create his own following. So
Jesus was preaching a message that is
different from John the Baptist. Okay.
So that's the second thing we know. The
third thing that we know is the
crucification
the crucifixion. Okay. So we know that
the Romans crucified Jesus. We don't
know why. We know that the Romans killed
Jesus. And crucification is when the
Romans nail you onto a wooden cross.
Okay? And it's an awful way to die
because how you're dying is actually not
through the bleeding. Okay? You got
nails uh hammered to the cross. You're
dying because you have no energy. So
your your your head hangs low, which
means you're suffocating slowly. And it
takes about 3 days for you to suffocate
to death. And so this is like one of the
worst punishments that the Romans could
ever inflict on you. And really there's
only two sets of people that the Romans
will use crucification as punishment.
Okay? The first type are thieves and
bandits. All right? These are considered
like the lowest type of people. The
second type of people are rebels.
People who are trying to overthrow the
Roman state. Okay.
Um, so Jesus, in other words, was
probably a rebel or the Romans
considered him a rebel. Okay, so that's
the third thing that we know for sure.
Now, the last thing that we know for
sure is that a brother called James the
Just.
And James the Just would inherit Jesus'
movement after the death of Jesus. And
this movement was called the poor or
another word for this is Ibionites.
Okay, don't worry about the name. Just
remember the idea. Okay, so these are
only the four things that we know for
sure about Jesus. Now, what I'm going to
do is I'm going to explain to you what
the Bible says about Jesus, what the
official story of Jesus is in the Bible,
and you can see how different it is from
what we know for sure. Okay, so this is
what the Bible says. Something to keep
keep in mind is that there are at least
four different biographies of Jesus in
the Bible. Uh Mark, Matthew, Luke, and
John. And they say different things, but
these but we'll talk about the main
story of Jesus. Okay. So the main story
of Jesus is that um Jesus
is the son of God.
And at this point in history,
we have disobeyed God. And God is angry
at us. And Jesus being the son of God
wants to redeem us in the eyes of God.
Remember, we try to become God. We try
to kill God by eating from the fruit,
eating the fruit from the tree of
knowledge. Okay? And so now God's angry
at us and we can't forgive ourselves. So
God so Jesus decides he must come to the
planet earth and and take a human form
and then sacrifice himself as a
scapegoat in order to redeem us in the
eyes of God. Okay, that's the plan. So
what he does is he comes and then he
starts a ministry.
All right? And what the ministry is is
it basically is healing people. Okay? So
he goes around healing people. If you
touch him, you're cure of cancer, you're
cure of all your diseases. Okay? He also
dispels demons. So there are some demons
inside of us. And what Jesus will do is
get rid of these demons and cleanse us.
Okay? And then he preaches the gospel,
the good news. So he teaches how to be
good people basically. The problem
though is that a lot of his teachings go
against
Judeaic authority. Okay? So at this time
remember he is in um Judea, the Roman
province of Judea and Jewish priests are
in charge and Jewish priests teach
people to follow the law to follow the
Sabbath. Okay, do not work on Saturdays,
obey the law of Moses, obey the customs
and traditions of the Jewish tradition.
And what Jesus says is no, what's
important is to um follow the spirit of
God. So there's a conflict here, okay?
Where Jesus is rebelling against the
authority of the Jewish priest, okay?
And so what happens is the Jewish
priests uh start to plot against Jesus
and eventually Jesus is betrayed by one
of his disciples, Judas Escariat. And
Jesus is um detained by the Jewish
priests who then give him over to the
Roman authorities. Okay. At this point,
Pontius Pilate
is
um
the governor of Judea. And so he asked
Jesus, "What did you do wrong?
Why do the Jewish priests want uh you to
be executed? And Jesus refuses to
answer. Pontious Pilot doesn't really
want to kill him, but there's anger from
the Jewish people who demand his head.
So, um Pontious Pilate orders Jesus to
be crucified
and then and then he dies. Okay. Jewish
Jesus dies
and then he's resurrected
after 3 days and then and then he
returns and appears before his disciples
and tells them, "I will come back. I
need to go to heaven, but I will come
back when I am most needed. Before I
come back, tell them the gospel. Tell
them the good news that I will one day
return and that I've redeemed people
from their sins." And therefore, it
doesn't matter if you're Jewish or not
Jewish. You can all celebrate God. Okay?
I brought God to you because I've
redeemed you from your sins. So tell
everyone the good news. All right? And
so this begins the very idea of
Christianity.
All right? Okay. So this is the official
story that you see in the Bible and this
is what most Christians believe. But
again, the problem of course is there
are lots of issues with this story.
Okay, so let's go over some of the major
issues. The first major issue is
[snorts]
what does God have a son?
How does how does God produce a son?
Aren't we all God's children? Why is
Jesus different from everyone else?
Okay. So, in Greek mythology, the gods
come down and impregnate a woman, but
that's not what happened here. It's just
the Bible says that God had a son and we
don't know where he came from. Okay, so
this is very confusing. But not only
that, but but the Bible also says that
Jesus is God. And so this is like really
confusing. Is he a son of God or is he
God? Okay, so this this is the first
major problem. Second major problem is
um why is he choosing to sacrifice
himself?
How does that resolve the issue? Right?
We disobey God and now Jesus will
um
redeem us by sacrificing himself. But
how does that work? Okay, the logic is
is kind of confusing. The third problem
and this actually very problem
problematic is the Bible is explicit. It
says that the Jewish priests plotted
against Jesus and the Jewish priests
were responsible for the death of Jesus.
And it's problematic because
for 2,000 years, Christians have used
this as a reason to persecute Jews
because you killed our Lord, our Savior.
Okay? You Jews are evil. Okay? Um but if
you look at Jewish history, I will argue
that this could not have happened. Okay,
it could have it could have happened for
like three reasons. The first reason is
okay, let's just say that Jesus was
rebelling against the Jewish priest.
Jesus was in disagreement with the
Jewish priest. That's not enough reason
for the priest to want to kill Jesus.
The reason why is within the Jewish
tradition
it is okay to argue. Okay. So at this
time in history there are at least three
different Jewish groups. Okay. They are
called the seduces.
Who are the seduces? The seduces are the
royalty of the religion. These are
priests that go back generations.
Okay. So this is like the Jewish
nobility. They call the seduces. Then
you have the Pharisees.
The Pharisees
are believe themselves to be reformers.
The seduces they maintain ritual. Okay?
So if you are to sacrifice an animal in
the temple, you have to go through them.
The Pharisees says sacrifice is not
what's important. What's important is
obeying the law. Okay? So there's a
major disagreement between the the
Pharisees and the seduces. Okay? But
then you also have the Essenes. who the
scenes these scenes are people who
become monks and they believe like John
the Baptist we believe that John the
Baptist was in a scene that God is
coming and there'll be a final war and
we must prepare for that so we must
abandon all materialistic belongings
okay guess what guys there are also
other groups within these different
groups and all three groups hate each
other okay so just because you disagree
with the Jewish authority is doesn't
mean they kill you. They just it's it's
in the Jewish tradition to argue all the
time. In fact, if you go to Israel
today, even though that they're at war,
they're still arguing with each other.
Okay, that's the first thing.
Disagreement, rebellion, uh debate is
just part of Jewish tradition. That's
the first thing. Second thing is like
there are certain customs and laws of
the Jewish people. Okay? The Jewish
people see themselves as distinct and
separate from everyone else because they
are the chosen people. And as we
discussed before, they're the Jewish
people um they must rest on Saturdays
and they do not marry foreign men or
woman. They don't marry outside their
tribe. Okay. So these are two uh major
customs. But they also as we discussed
before they also don't charge interest
when they give loans to each other.
Okay. Another thing that that is not
written down but which is commonly
commonly accepted is
you do not betray other Jews to the
Roman authorities. Okay. Does that make
sense? Okay. We can argue amongst
ourselves but we will not betray each
other to non-Jews.
Okay. we will not fight among
um the Romans.
That's just is an unwritten law at this
time. So um I don't think ever in
history have we had a case where the
Jewish people betrayed a Jew to the
authorities that was non-Jewish. Okay.
The Jewish people again see themselves
as separate and distinct from other
people. So they would not do this. The
third thing,
the third piece of evidence that that
this didn't happen is remember James the
just is a brother of Jesus. And after
Jesus died, James the just stayed in
Jerusalem protected by the Jewish
authorities.
That makes no sense, right? If Jesus, if
his teachings went against
Jewish law and that's why the Jewish
priest had him killed, then why did why
was James the just who was teaching the
same thing as Jesus allowed to stay in
Jerusalem? And not only allowed to stay
in Jerusalem, but protected by the Jews.
Okay. So, I'm not convinced that the
Jews betrayed him. Also remember we
discussed this last class but the Romans
are just brutal people. They killed
people for no particular reason. So um
they killed Jesus. They didn't care.
Okay. All right. So I think it's much
more likely the Romans killed Jesus for
their own reasons as opposed to the um
Jew Jews killed Jesus. Yes. Uh, so the
real group that killed Jesus is the Jews
or the Roman.
>> So yeah, I'm saying it's the Romans who
killed Jesus. And we all agree it was
the Romans who killed Jesus. What the
Bible says is that it was the Jews who
conspired against Jesus and the Jews
encouraged the Romans to to kill Jesus.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> All right. All right. So that's another
question. Why did the Jews conspire
against uh Jesus? And again, I think the
story is not true. Then you have the the
idea of like Jesus dies. So the question
then is if you're a son of God, you're
divine, how do you die? And does death
have any meaning? Okay. And then of
course you have the resurrection. Like
why would you resurrect yourself? And
the second coming, okay,
why would you want to come back? Why do
you need to come back? You've already
redeemed humanity. Why do you have to
come back? And then uh why do you have
why do you have to let people know who
you are? You're going to redeem
humanity. Why do people have to worship
you? Why do people have to celebrate
you? Okay. So this this raised a lot of
questions and again no other religion
has this many questions. And so what the
explanation is is
uh miracle,
mystery,
magic. Okay, this is the standard
explanation if you talk to Christians.
Why is this all happening? Don't
question it. Just believe it. Just
embrace it. Okay? But in our class, we
don't really do that. We ask questions.
We speculate. So, um, I know there are
two billion Christians in the world and
I'm sure they love Jesus, but in our
class, we're really trying to figure out
who he is. Okay? So, what I'm what we
want to figure out today is first of
all, what did Jesus believe? Okay,
what did he teach? Because it's not it's
not really clear. Okay? I'm sure Jesus
did not preach, did not teach, believe
in me and you, you'll be saved. Okay? He
probably did not do that. Christians
tell you that but Jesus himself probably
did not teach that. Okay, that's the
first thing. Second question is why did
he become so popular? What was it about
his belief that made him popular?
Okay. And the third thing is why did the
Romans kill him?
Right. So these are the three big
questions we're looking at today. First
of all, what did Jesus really believe?
Second is why was he so popular? And the
third question is whether Romans have to
kill him. And so um the argument I want
to make you today is what Jesus taught
is what every poet prophet we studied
this semester taught as well. Okay. So
you look at Homer, you look at the
Yahweh, you you look at Zorathustra,
Plato. What do they all teach? They all
teach that there is a source. Okay. The
source is the vine, the good, God, the
universe, the monac, whatever name you
have for it. Okay. And this the source
emanates and it creates the entire
universe and we come from the source.
Now our bodies are material. Okay. So
our our bodies come from a process of
evolution but our consciousness our soul
is a divine spark
and it comes from the source. So after
our experience here on earth, after we
die, our source, our spark goes back to
the source. Okay? And there's a constant
cycle until we at at the end merge to
the source. Okay? This is what Buddhism
teaches. This is what Hinduism teaches.
This is what uh Zoroastrianism, this is
what all major religions teach. Okay? So
Jesus was just teaching it for his
times. So the question then is if he is
teaching what every person every port
prophet taught why is he special? He's
special because the Roman Empire was
particularly evil. Okay so remember
before the Roman Empire
um
remember the problem of the Iliad. Okay
remember the Iliad where Achilles cannot
forgive himself and his prime who
forgave him. Right? And we discussed how
uh during the Iliad
uh during that time
we all did good and we all did evil. And
so what's important is for forgive
ourselves, right? As long as we find the
power to forgive ourselves, we will save
the world. But by the time of the
Romans, okay, the Romans are just pure
evil. They're demonic. And so you don't
forgive yourself, right? And so the
question then is how do you explain the
fact that the Romans are able to conquer
the world for pure evil and you a person
they're all good but you're a slave. How
do you explain that? How do you find
comfort? How do you find source on the
fact that you've done good in your life
but at the same time evil triumphs?
Okay. And the message that Jesus came is
to help people understand why the Romans
triumph. Okay. And what Jesus will say
is this. The Romans triumph because the
world that we live in is a false world.
It is a corpse. It's a dead world. This
is not the true world. So those who most
embrace
death and evil and hatred will win in
this world. But this is a false world.
What matters is up there. Okay?
So and so what you need to understand is
this. The Romans have won
by being evil. So in the grand scheme of
things, they've lost.
Okay, so think about Achilles. How did
Achilles
get what he wanted? He betrayed
Petroles, right? He sacrificed Petroas.
But because he knows he did evil, he
can't sleep. He can't eat. He He cannot
rest. All he has all he can do is
mutilate Hector's body. And that's just
the Roman way. What Jesus is telling us
is this. I know the world is evil. I
know that the rich, the powerful
oppress us and we hate them. But use our
imagination, use our heart, use our
empathy and look into
their minds and you can see how
tormented they are. how every day they
live with demons that haunt them, how
they can't sleep, how how they hate
themselves, and how they hate hate the
world around them. And then when you see
that for yourself, what you will see is
they're more pitiful than you are. You
may be poor,
but you're at least you're not haunted
by demons. Okay?
And so if you really want to do good in
the world, you have to forgive your
enemy. You have to love your enemy
because only by loving your enemy can
you release your enemy from his demons
and that will save the world. Okay? So
what Jesus is telling us is this. The
enemies,
the people who oppress us, the rich, the
powerful, they are Achilles. Okay? They
are Achilles after they've killed Hector
and they have absolutely no purpose in
life. They're haunted by demons. And we
have to be ply. We have to kiss Achilles
hand, submit before him so that he can
be released from his demons. And this
will make the world a better place.
Okay, that is the message of Jesus. And
that is our mission in our in this world
in a time of evil in a place of evil to
look at our hearts to look in the hearts
of other people to forgive our enemies
to let go of our hatred and to forgive
our enemies and then that will save the
world.
Okay, that is the central message of
Jesus. All right,
any questions before we look at the
evidence? Okay. So, I present to you the
argument. Okay. The argument is this.
Jesus taught a message of love and
forgiveness. And that's what made him
popular because
it reminds people of who they are.
Right? You may be a slave. You may think
you're worthless. But Jesus is telling
you there's still a spark inside of you
that connects you to the monad. And as
long as you use love, forgiveness,
compassion, this spark will activate and
it will release you from your slavery.
Okay, this is a false world. Once that
spark is activated, you will see the
world as false and that will free you.
Okay, and why the Romans kill him? The
Romans killed him because Jesus was a
rebel. He was trying to subvert the
natural order, right? The natural order
is the Romans at the top, the slaves at
the very bottom. And Jesus is saying,
"No, it's the opposite. Slaves at the
top, Romans at the bottom." Okay?
Because the Romans are trapped and
cursed by the evil in their hearts.
Whereas the slaves are free and they can
liberate everyone through their
compassion, through their love, through
their forgiveness. Okay? And that's why
the Roman psalm is a threat.
Does that make sense, guys? Okay? And
that's why they had to kill him.
All right? Right? And then they made up
the sto the the Bible in order to
um
um justify what they did. Okay? Because
as we discussed last class, that's what
Romans do. Okay? They do evil and then
they get get the Greeks or the Jews to
write the history to explain why it was
good. Okay? So in other words, and this
this is something that I will discuss
next class is all right. And I I I know
this is hard to understand, but I'll
explain it next class. Is
this story guys,
it was the Romans who wrote this story.
Okay? Because as you can see, this story
convened conveniently excuse the Romans
from all blame even though it was the
Romans who killed Jesus. And it puts all
the blames on Jews. Okay, that's the
intention of the Bible,
right? So Christianity is not an
invention of Jesus.
Christianity is invention of the
romance. Okay. And that's something I
will show you next class. Okay.
[clears throat]
All right. But are we clear before I go
into the evidence? Okay. All right.
All right. So the line spark of Jesus.
Okay. So the idea here is this.
Um if you read Homer, the Iliad, the
Odyssey, if you read Dante, Divine
Comedy, if you read any of the great
books, you will you will
see the divine spark reflected in you.
Okay. The these great books are a portal
into the divine. The problem though is
most people cannot read the Iliad or the
Divine Comedy. Okay. So the question
then is what do the common people do and
the answer is Jesus is a portal into the
vine right so if you just remember the
life of Jesus if you just recite his
sayings that will give you access to the
vine that will remind you of who you are
so yes Homer and Dante are great I love
Homer and Dante but you have to be very
educated in order to read Homer and
Dante well whereas Jesus anyone can know
the story of Jesus anyone can um um say
what he says and then that will give you
access to the vine. Okay.
So Jesus is really about the
democratization
of the divine. Okay. Jesus allows anyone
to access the divine whereas before um
you have to access the vine through
poetry. Okay. All right. So um the life
of Jesus. Okay. So again
Jesus is Jewish. So the center of Jewish
life is uh Jerusalem. Okay. Right here.
Jerusalem. And in the center of
Jerusalem is a temple which was rebuilt
uh under the Persians. Right. Uh and
Herod will will will rebuild this. We
renate this. Okay. Um so we know that
Jesus was born in this area Galilee. As
you can see, Galilee is by the coast,
which makes this region extremely
cosmopolitan. So from an early age,
Jesus is experiencing different
religions, different cultures, Hinduism,
Zorashinism,
um, Judaism. Okay.
All right. So, uh, this is an AI
depiction of the crucification,
crucifixion of Jesus. Jesus is in the
middle and as you can see it is a brutal
event.
Okay. Um so we don't know much about
Jesus. We only know um um Jesus from the
Bible. Then in 1945
in a place called N Hamadi. Okay this is
in Egypt. We discovered lots of books
with sayings of Jesus that we didn't
know existed before. So what's important
to understand is that after Jesus died,
there were many different sects of
Christianity that believed different
things and they argued with each other
and ultimately it was the Catholic
Church who won. Why? Because the
Catholic Church is run by the Roman
Empire. Okay. Um so one major book that
was discovered in in the uh in 1945 in
Hamatti that was lost to us is called
the gospel of Thomas. And what I believe
is the gospel of Thomas
uh records the true teachings of Jesus.
Okay. So let's first let's first look at
the true teachings of Jesus and then we
I'll explain to you why I think this is
actually his true teachings. All right.
So um can you read the highlighted part?
Okay.
>> And he said whoever finds interpretation
of these saying will not experience
death.
>> Okay. All right. So okay listen this
already makes sense right because in the
universe death doesn't exist because
after you die your soul goes up to the
astral plane to the vine. Okay? So you
your soul can never die. But you have to
recognize that you are the divine spark.
Okay? You first need to recognize that.
Once you recognize that, you'll be
immortal. But if you don't recognize
that, then you fear death. Okay?
Jesus said, "Let him who seeks continue
seeking until he finds. When he finds,
he will become troubled. When he become
troubled, he will be astonished and he
will rule over the all." Okay, so this
goes back to the Plato's allegory of the
cave, right? Right. Plato's algo of the
cave is this prisoner who escapes his
chains, he goes up into the real world
where there's sunlight and he sees the
truth, right? And now he's able to see
whereas everyone else is still chained
as prisoners in the cave. And now he
rules overall because he knows the
truth. Whereas everyone else is still in
prison in darkness. But remember that
this is a painful process. When you go
in the light, you're blinded by it. You
feel absolute pain. You feel uh
confusion. But over time, if you
persist, you will see the truth. Okay.
So this is the cave. Okay. Keep on
going. Jesus said, "If those who lead
you say to you, see the kingdom is in
the sky, then the birds of the sky will
precede you. If they say to you, it is
in the sea," then the fish will precede
you. Rather, the kingdom is inside of
you and it is outside of you. When you
comes to know yourself, then you will
become known and you will realize that
it is you who are the sons of living
father. But if you will not know
yourselves, you dwell in poverty. And is
it is you who are that poverty.
>> Okay. So this is really important idea.
Okay. Going back to the cave. When you
escape the the cave and you see the real
world and you come back, it doesn't
matter if you tell them what the real
real world is. Okay? It doesn't matter
if they believe you. They themselves
have to go out and see the world for
themselves. Okay? They have to break the
chains themselves and then venture out
into the light and experience pain and
torment for themselves before they
recognize the truth. Okay? That's what
Jesus is saying. They people
[clears throat] who tell you this stuff
don't listen to them. Okay? They can
only guide you. But you can't trust
them. You can't believe in them. You
have to believe in yourself. You have to
look into yourself because the truth
divine spark is inside of you. Okay? So
what Jesus is saying is this organized
religion does not work guys. So there's
no way Jesus would say follow me and
you're good. Believe in me and you're
good. He would never ever say that
because he knows you can't follow
someone else. You have to believe in
yourself. The divine spark is in you.
Okay? Doesn't make sense.
So they are lying to you. When they say
the kingdom is in heaven, don't believe
them. Okay? Another thing that you will
notice is
we're all sons of the living father. You
understand? Jesus is not like I'm the
son of God and you're not. I'm superior
to you. They're saying we're all
sons of the living father. Okay. Also,
and this is really important, he
actually doesn't throughout the gospel
of humus, he actually doesn't refer to
the Bible. Okay? He doesn't talk about
Adam and Eve. He doesn't talk about
Yahweh. He doesn't talk about David.
doesn't talk about Moses because for him
it's all fake. Okay. The Bible is fake.
What's true is divine spark in you.
Okay.
All right. So again, all this is
contradictory modern day Christianity
because Jesus was not a Christian. Okay.
Keep on going.
Oh, sorry. Uh let's let's keep on going.
And again guys, what what what you're
seeing is this the similar between the
go of Thomas and Plato's algorith of the
cave and the Iliad and Zorustra his
teachings as well as Niti. Okay, you see
how all these poor prophets, they all
think alike. They're expressing things
differently. They're talking to a
different age and a different audience,
but basically saying the same thing.
Okay, this is really important. All
right, continue reading, please.
>> Jesus saw infants being suckled. He said
to his disciples, "These infants being
suckled are like those who enter the
kingdom." They said to him, "Shall we
then as children enter the kingdom?"
Jesus said to them, "When you make the
two one, and when you make the inside
like the outside, and the outside like
the inside, and the above like the
below, and when you make the male and
the female one and the same, so that the
male not be male, nor the female. And
when you f when you fashion eyes in the
place of an eye and a hands in place of
a hand and a foot in place of a foot and
a likeness in place of a likeness then
will enter the kingdom.
>> Okay. So um again this is similar to
what we've learned before right what
he's saying is this we are born into
this world and as we grow older we
believe in the falseeness that we see
around us. Okay. But once we develop our
imagination and once we recognize that
this world that we live in is our
hallucination, it is just a projection
of our imagination. Then we can take
control over this world and then that
will allow us to access the vibe. Okay?
It is through the imagination which
allows us to access the vine and it will
allow us to create this world in a new
place. We're able to see fashion eyes in
the place of an eye, a hand in the place
of a hand. We're able to be our true
selves. Okay? And what we will
understand is that we're all connected
by the vine. The separation of like
male, female,
okay? Chinese, American,
black, white, it's all made up. It's not
true. Once we able to see reality as it
is, we'll all be one and the same. When
you make the two one, we make the inside
like the outside and the outside the
inside and the above like the below.
We're all interconnected together. Okay?
We're all part of the same source. We we
have to train ourselves to see the truth
from this falsehood.
Okay. So again the idea of asha and
douch right this is asha moving towards
the interconnectedness of all things the
harmony of all things. The is the
division of all things. Okay. [snorts]
[clears throat]
All right.
His disciples said to him, "Show us a
place where you are since it is
necessary for you to si for us to seek
it sack seek it." He said to them,
"Whoever has ears, let him hear. There
is light within the man of light and he
lights up the whole world. If he does
not shine, he is darkness."
>> Okay. So the disciple says to Jesus,
"Tell us how to be like you." And Jesus
says, "Be yourself. There's a light
inside of you." Okay? look for the light
and and like shine the world.
Okay.
All right. Keep on going. Jesus said, "I
took my place in the midst of the world,
and I appeared to them in flesh. I found
all of them intoxicated. I found none of
them thirsty. And my soul become afflict
afflicted for the sons of men because
they are blind in their hearts and do
not have sight. For empty they came into
the world and empty too they seek to
live the world but for the moment they
are intoxicated. When they shake off
their wine then they will re repeat
repent. Jesus said if the flesh came
into being because of spirit it is a
wonder. But if spirit came into being
because of the body it is a wonder of
wonders. Indeed, I am amazed at how this
great wealth have made its home in its
poverty.
>> Wait, so he's talking about the
materialistic world. Okay, we came into
this world with nothing. And guess what?
When we die, we're going to go back with
nothing. Okay, so this pursuit of
materialism, this pursuit of wealth,
this pursuit of power makes no sense.
Why are you here pursuing all this
stuff, this gold, this wealth, this
money that you can't take with you? it
it seems as though you're drunk. Okay,
so this line, the flesh came into being
because of spirit is a wonder. Okay, so
the idea is that it is the
consciousness, the mind that creates the
the material world, the body, right?
That makes sense. And what Jesus is
saying is this. If you think that the
body
creates the spirit, you're crazy. It's
impossible. It's a wonder of wonders.
That's impossible, guys. Why? Because
the spirit is full of wealth. The body
is impoverished. How is it possible that
that an impoverished body is able to
create so much wealth? Okay. And this
makes sense, right? Our mind, our
consciousness is so vast, so abundant,
but our bodies are so limited. So how is
it possible that our smaller brains is
able to create a universe of ideas and
experiences? Okay.
All right. So the idea of intoxicated,
we're here and we're just drunk, but we
are not thirsty for the truth. We're
happy for the way it is. Okay.
All right. And this idea is mirrored in
a poem that we read before by Roomie,
right? So you may remember uh Roomie,
the Persian poet. He also says this, the
world that we live in is a prison for
drunks.
Okay. So, I'm pretty sure roommate did
not read Jesus Gospel of Thomas. But
they're able to think the same thoughts
because they're all being inspired by
the same source. Does that make sense?
All right. Continue, please.
>> Yeah. Jesus said, "The phrases and the
scribes have taken the keys of
knowledge." Uh, this is
>> Nostis. Nostis means knowledge. Okay.
and hidden them. They themselves have
not entered, nor have they allowed to
enter those who wish to. You, however,
be as wise as serpents and as innocent
as dogs. Okay, so Jesus hates organized
religion. Okay, the Pharisees remember
are Jewish priests, Jewish leaders, and
they create a hierarchy of religion
where they say to people, only I know
the truth, only I have knowledge, so
listen to me. And what Jesus is saying
is they themselves are ignorant because
you cannot access knowledge through
hierarchy. Okay, through oppressing
other people. You can only access
knowledge by looking into yourself. So
you have to become like the serpent and
pretend you don't know anything in order
to access knowledge yourself because
otherwise if you are capable accessing
knowledge then the priest will see as a
threat and they will kill you. All
right. And what he's the serpent
remember it was a serpent who told Eve
to eat from the fruit. And so what Jesus
is saying is it is good and natural to
seek knowledge even if it means those
disobeying God.
Okay? That's what we're meant to do
here. To seek knowledge, to seek the
truth, to seek love. If the the gods, if
the priests stop you from doing so, it's
because you're evil.
All right? Because remember the true
God, the monad is pure love, pure
compassion, pure forgiveness. He can do
no wrong. He's perfection. And if you
have the desire to seek knowledge and
you believe that knowledge makes you a
happier, more fulfilled person, then you
should seek knowledge. Even if God tells
you don't do so, because if that God
tells you don't do so, it means he's a
false god.
Okay, keep on going.
Jesus said, "Whoever has come to
understand the world as found only a
corpse, and whoever has found a corpse
is superior to the world." Okay, so this
is this is what's going to get Jesus in
trouble, right? He's saying the Roman
Empire, this great empire that you've
built that ranges across the
Mediterranean, it's a corpse. It's
dying. It's dead. It's nothing.
All right? Right? And once you recognize
this, once you refuse to comply, once
you refuse to obey, they have no power
over you. Right? And so that's a threat
to power. That's a threat to the Roman
Empire. Keep on going. Jesus said, "The
kingdom is like a shafir who had
shepherd who had a hund sheep. One of
them, the largest went astray. He left
the 99 sheep and looked for that one
until he found it. When he had gone to
such trouble, he said to the ship, I
care for you more than the 99.
>> Okay? So God, the true God, does not
want obedience. He wants us to be
creative. He wants us to seek knowledge.
He wants us to discover. He wants us to
explore. He wants to try new things. And
if we do this, he cares for us than
those who obey him. Because those who
obey him, those who do nothing,
contribute nothing to the universe.
Okay. When we love, when we imagine, we
are making the universe a brighter
place. We are shining our light. We just
sit back and just do what we're told.
We're doing nothing. Okay. We're We're
like NPCs. Do you guys know NPCs?
Non-playable characters in in video
game. Okay. We don't we don't exist.
All right. Keep on going.
Jesus said, "A man had received
visitors, and when he had prepared the
dinner, he sent his servant to invite
the guys. He went to the first one and
said to him, "My master invites you." He
said, "I have claimed again some
merchants. They are coming to me this
evening. I must go and give them my
orders. I asked to be excused from the
dinner." He went to another and said to
him, "My master have has invited you."
He said to him, "I have just bought a
house and and am required for the day. I
shall not have any spare time." He went
to another and said to him, "My master
invites you." He said to him, "My
friends is going to get married and I am
to prepare the banquet. I shall not be
able to come. I ask to be excused from
the dinner." He went to another and said
to him, "My master in advised you." He
said to him, "I have just bought a farm
and I'm on my way to collect the rent. I
should not be able to come. I asked to
be excused." The servant returned and
said to his master, "Those whom you
invited to the dinner have asked to be
excused." The master said to his
servant, "Go outside to the streets and
bring back those whom you happen to meet
so that they may dine." businessmen and
merchants will not enter the places of
my father.
>> Okay? So again, this goes against the
empire. What Jesus is saying is the
worst people in this world are the rich
people. Okay? Think think about today
how we're supposed to worship Elas,
right? Because he's he's he's rich. What
Jesus is saying is no, Elmas is the
worst person in the world. Why? Because
the divine, the monad has prepared a
great feast for us. When we die, when we
go with to to a monad, we will
experience the greatest happiness, the
greatest joy. Okay? The monad's inviting
us, but the business people are saying,
"No, I'm too busy. I'm too busy making
money. I'm too busy doing evil in this
world. So, I don't want to go to the
stupid feast."
So, they're the ones who will lose out
in the end, even though today we think
they've won out. Okay? So, that's what
Jesus is saying. Jesus is like, "Don't
worry about the rich and the powerful.
They may look happy, but they're not."
At the end of days, when we all go back
to the Monad, we all go back to the
vine, they're the ones who will not be
invited to the grand feast. Yeah.
>> Uh I have a question that God let us to
be creative and like do our thing that
we want to do like seek for the spark.
But since we are born, how can we really
know the things that what we want to do?
Uh like I think that requires
socialization between other people. But
if you socialize, they will brainwash
you and affect to let you to seek for
materialism.
>> Yeah. Okay. That's a great question and
and it's a problem, right? Because as
you say, your parents, the school,
society brainwashes you to believe that
only money matters, only grades matter.
Okay. And the answer is you have to be
brave. You have to be true to yourself
because you yourself know what is true.
Right? If we didn't know then Jesus
would not matter. Why do two billion
people believe in Jesus? Because they
know that Jesus spoke the truth.
Okay? So listen to your heart. I know
it's hard and most of us cannot do it.
Okay? And that's why um in many
traditions like like Buddhism and
Hinduism reincarnation is important
because maybe in this lifetime we don't
figure it out. Maybe in the next
lifetime but maybe then you know 50
lifetimes away but eventually you'll
figure it out. Eventually you'll figure
out that what other people say does not
matter because this world we live in is
a false world. Eventually you'll figure
that out and then you're like you know
what I should do? I should do what I
believe to be true. And then and then
what you recognize is, oh, when I
actually do what I like, what I enjoy,
it makes me a more fulfilled person. And
guess what? It connects me to the vine.
Okay? I am a much more spiritual person
now.
And you can know because look at
people's faces, right? When you meet a
rich person,
his face is kind of, I don't know, evil.
When you when you meet a person who's
generous, who volunteers his time, who
is a good teacher, his face is
different. Okay? So remember Achilles,
when you do evil, evil comes into you
and it corrupts your soul. When you do
good, good comes to you and it brightens
your soul and you brighten the world
with it. Okay?
But without like education and
socialization like if we are an infant
how do we know what is right or wrong
and what should we seek for? Because of
the spark in you right because of the
spark in you. You know and it glows.
When you love someone
and that person loves you back your
spark glows. When you become a teacher
and you teach students, your teach your
students learn well, your spark glows.
>> So like you try different things until
the you find the things that make your
spark glow.
>> Yeah. And and say the important idea is
that our lives are infinite. Okay. So we
will die and die is like a game reset.
Okay. It's just like you suck at this
game, you die, you come back and you try
again. Okay. But it's your choice. The a
really important idea here is free will.
It's your choice to do whatever you want
with your life. No one's going to force
you. Okay? So, the idea of when you die
is you go back uh to the astral plane
and then you're able to reflect on your
own life and then you come back and you
start over. Eventually, you'll figure it
out. It may take a million years. It may
take a thousand years. Who knows? But
eventually, you'll figure it out. Okay?
Because because the world is infinite.
Does does that make sense? Okay.
What's really important to understand is
you have to figure out it by yourself.
No one can teach you. I can give you the
idea. Jesus can tell you what he thinks,
but you have to figure out by yourself.
Okay? And that's why this is so hard for
people to accept because people don't
want to accept individual
responsibility.
Okay? [snorts]
All right. Okay. So this this gives us
um um so so the problem is this. The
problem is that Jesus says that you
there's a spark inside of you and it's
your responsibility. You don't have to
but it's your responsibility
to let it grow. If you let it grow you
will bring happiness to the world.
You'll bring happiness to yourself and
then you will able to feast with a mon
with a vine um in heaven. Okay. And as I
said um as we discussed it's hard man
it's really hard you think individual
responsibility you have to ignore people
around you. You have to uh learn for
yourself.
So you know this idea maybe a few people
thousands tens of thousands will love
this idea
but what about the millions of other
people who just want to like live normal
lives? what can we do about them? Okay,
so this is uh the book the brothers Kara
Mazoff by Theodor Dossi.
He's talking about the problem left by
Jesus. Jesus comes to the world. He
tells us the truth. He tells us freedom
is what will enable us to seek the vine.
But this creates this anxiety in people
because like oh my god now I have to
like think for myself. Now I have to
like go out into the light and feel all
this pain. But I don't want to. I just
want to live a happy life. I just want
to watch TV every day, man.
And then so
um and and so then the church is like,
okay, we need to create an organized
religion and we need to fool people.
Okay, how do we fool people? By teaching
them
that Jesus didn't actually say these
things. And we're going to not we will
we will not worship Jesus. We worship
Satan instead. Why? Because Satan
encourages us to enforce our will on
people. Okay? We need to be evil in
order to do good in the world.
Okay? Think about this. These children
are naughty, right? Now, we can say to
them like Jesus, hey man, you'll grow up
one day and then you won't be naughty.
So, okay. But in this process, you're
going to hurt each other. You're going
to do stupid things. So, we have to be
the strict father. We have to create
this church in order to enforce the law
on people to make sure the children
don't hurt themselves so that children
can just be children. Okay? And quite
honestly, most of you guys, 99% of you
guys will never ever grow up. So, we
have to be Satan. Okay? So, the church,
the Catholic Church, will pretend to
worship Jesus, but actually we're going
to worship Satan.
And so, we're going to enforce the law
on people. We will now be the evil
empire. The Roman Empire is dead. Okay?
But now the Catholic Church will be the
evil empire and we're going to go around
and we're going to persecute people who
disobey the law so that everyone can
live in peace. People want to be sheep.
And you know what? People have the right
to be sheep. And so we're going to be
the shepherd. We will be Satan. And we
will enforce
goodness on people whether they like it
or not. And this is good for people
because now they don't have to accept
individual responsibility. Right? If my
life sucks, it's not because of me. It's
because of the devil. It's because of
the Catholic Church. is because of Satan
and that's what's good. Okay,
so Dasc is saying this is how the
Catholic Church came into being and
we'll discuss this next class in more
detail. Okay, because Jesus left a huge
problem a void in the hearts of people.
People want to obey. People want to be
told what to do. People don't want to
think for themselves. If you make people
think for themselves, they'll feel
nothing but fear and anxiety. Okay?
Right? So we need to impose order.
So in this story what happens is the
Catholic church is being is being the
evil empire. It is oppressing people.
And so one day Jesus comes from heaven
and he walks among the people and people
will know oh my god he's Jesus he's come
back and he's curing people and they're
all happy and but because the Catholic
church worships Satan they need to
arrest this guy. Okay. And the grand
inquisitor the leader appears before
Jesus. They have a conversation that
Jesus is called a prisoner in the story
and he says to the prisoner, "We know
who you are. You are Jesus and we're
supposed to worship you, but we're going
to have to kill you because you are a
threat to the people. You're a threat to
the happiness of the people." Okay? And
what the grandchild will say to Jesus
is,
"We create good in this world by being
evil and your presence will destroy this
and therefore we must destroy you."
Okay. So this is from the brothers K
maz. Okay.
Thou this. Okay. Thou does not love them
at all. Thou who does come to give thy
life for them. Instead of taking
possession of man's freedom, thou does
increase it and burden the spiritual
kingdom of mankind with its suffering
forever.
>> Okay. So what he's saying is is you came
to this world to free people to tell
them that the not exists that there's a
spark inside them that they don't have
to be slaves they can they can go
wherever they want but that just
confuses people that traps people in
their own fear and anxiety.
Life now becomes complicated.
Okay, keep on going. Thou did desire
man's free love that he should follow
thee freely enticed and taken captive by
thee. In place of the rigid Asian law,
men must uh hereafter with free heart
decide for himself what is good and what
is evil. Having only thy image before
him as his guide.
>> Okay, this is okay. Sorry. This is like
really annoying, okay, for people
because before your teacher would tell
you what is good and what is evil. Now
the teacher is saying you guys decide
now it's complete chaos. Okay. And again
it creates anxiety in people. People
just want to be told what to do. Okay.
People were like, you know, at 5:00
we're going to have dinner um at Pizza
Hut. Okay. People don't want to be like,
"Uh, what what should I what should I
have for dinner?" Okay. People don't
want to think, man. Okay. Keep on going.
But this thou dot know that he would at
last reject even thy image and thy truth
if he is w uh weigh down with a fearful
burden of free choice. They will cry
aloud at last that the truth is not in
thee. For they could not have been left
in greater confusion and suffering than
thou has caused laying upon them so many
cars cares and unanswerable problems.
>> Okay. Right. You're creating all this
anxiety in people for no particular
reason. People were happy just being
slaves and now you free them and they're
completely confused as what to do next.
>> All right, keep on reading.
>> Only some thousands.
>> Okay. So, so what he's saying again is
your freedom is only good for the
minority of people who can think for
themselves
who aspire
uh to the divine. What about everyone
else? And what of the rest? And how are
the other weak ones to blame? Because
they cannot endure what the strong have
endured. How is the weak soul to blame
that it is unable to receive such
terrible gifts? Can thou have simply
came come to the elect and for the
elect? But if so, it is a mystery and we
cannot understand it. And if it is a
mystery, we too have a right to preach a
mystery and to teach them that it's not
the free judgment of their hearts, not
love that mattered, but a mystery which
they must follow blindly even against
their conscience. So we have John.
>> Okay. All right. So what he's saying is
this. Okay. I understand Christianity is
complete complete chaos. Okay. But this
complete chaos means people will never
understand what your true teachings are.
And if people don't understand what your
true teachings are, they don't have to
follow it. They don't have to think for
themselves. Okay? So we created complete
chaos so that people will not be forced
to obey us. Okay? That's why we
corrupted your teachings. Keep on going.
We have corrected thy work and have
funded it upon miracle, mystery, and
authority. And manly joy that they were
again led like sheep, and that the
terrible gift that had brought them such
suffering was at last lifted from their
hearts. Were we right teaching them
this? Speak. Do we not love mankind so
might meekly acknowledging their
feelessness, lovingly enlightening their
burden and permitting their weak nature
even sing or sanction? Why has thou come
now to ponder us?
>> Okay, do you understand this idea? They
understand is why is there evil in the
world? Because people don't want to
think for themselves. So you need evil
people to command people to enslave
people to force them against their will.
Now people are like, "Well, I don't have
a choice in the matter. I can't think
for myself. Sorry, man." Okay. If you
actually give people complete freedom,
it'd be complete chaos in the world.
That's why there's Satan. That's why
there's Satan in this world. This is why
Satan must rule this world.
Okay,
I meant to end it like this. When the
inquisitor ceased speaking, he waited
some time for his prisoner to answer
him. His silence weighed down upon him.
He saw that the president had listened
intently all the time, licking gently in
his face and evidently not wishing to
reply. The old man longed for him to say
something, however bitter and terrible,
but he suddenly approached an old man in
silence and softly kissed him on his
bloodness age lips. That was all his
answer. The old man shuddered. His lips
moved. He went to the door, opened it,
and said to him, "Go and come no more.
Come not all, not at all. Never, never."
And he led him out into the dark alleys
of the town. The prisoner went away. And
the old man, the keys close in his
heart, but the old man adheres to his
idea.
>> Okay, so the prison of course is Jesus,
right? And so the inquisitor has these
great arguments and the inquisitor is
right. And what he's saying is, "Okay,
Jesus,
what's your response to this?" And
Jesus' response is basically, "I forgive
you. I love you and I forgive you." Same
thing as what Prime did to Achilles,
right? And as you can see, by kissing
the the Inquisitor rather than fighting
him, the Inquisitor loses. He knows he's
lost. He knows he's been humbled. So he
lets Jesus go. Says, "Just get out of
here. Please don't bother us again."
Okay? This is not your world. This is
Satan's world. And the kiss glows in his
heart, but the old man aderes to his
ideas. Okay? So Jesus did not change the
old man's mind. Okay? But there's a
spark in him that now glows. Okay? the
spark that he killed that he tried all
this time to kill with reason with evil
is still able to grow glow. Okay? And
that's the power of forgiveness.
Even though the person seems to be the
most evil person in the world and this
guy really is the most evil person in
the world, as long as you're able to
show him the possibility of love, the
spark will glow. Okay. Now what's the So
the Inquisitor poses this problem like
okay people uh don't want to think for
themselves. People lack free will.
People don't want free will. What's the
solution? The solution is the soul is
eternal. Okay? And you have to give
people time. We're talking about like
millions of years. Maybe not in 50 years
people will figure it out, but in about
a million years people will figure it
out for themselves. Okay? And Jesus, God
is patient. He's loving. He's forgiving.
He's generous. He's compassionate. So,
take your time. Okay. What's important
is that people learn for themselves.
Eventually, you'll figure out being a
slave sucks. You know what? It may seem
as though watching Netflix, playing
video games, being online all the time
is fun. But if you go outside and play,
that's a lot more fun, guys. Eventually,
you'll figure it out. All right? and you
have fear by yourself. So God is forever
patient. Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, so next class we'll talk about the
Catholic Church and how it came into
being and why it is it really is the
church of Satan. All right, why it's
going to go go against this teaching of
Jesus. But do actually point this out
how the Catholic Church and Jesus are
com are competing forces. Okay.
All right.
Now, let's go on to Divine Comedy by
Dante. And again, Dante is trying to
answer the question, why did Jesus have
to kill himself? What's the logic of
that? That makes no sense. Okay? And
traditionally, what the Catholic Church
teaches people is
it's because when we do evil, we become
slaves of Satan.
So Jesus made a deal with Satan.
Basically Jesus says, "I will die
and then I will and then you can take my
body, okay? And then you will have to
free my people." And Satan is like,
"That's a really good deal, man. God for
exchange in exchange for the slaves.
Sure, I'll make that deal." But the
thing is that Jesus when he died and he
freed us, he cannot ever truly die.
Okay, does that make sense? So this is
called a ransom theory. And this is how
during Tan's time most people understood
why
uh Jesus had to die. Jesus died so that
we would stop being slaves of Satan and
now we are slaves to Jesus and that's
why we must worship Jesus. And Dian's
like no no no that can't possibly be
right. Okay. God did not come to free us
so that we become slaves to God. God
came to free us so that we could be
free. Okay. All right. So this is Dante.
And what's what's going to happen here
is in heaven there's going to be a
conversation between Dante and Beatrice
who he loves. Okay? And they're going to
discuss the nature of the universe. And
this is Beatric talking to Dante.
The greatest gift the magna magnanimity
of God as he created gave the gift most
suited to his goodness. Gift that he
most prices was a freedom of the world.
>> Okay. So the underlying principle of the
universe is freedom of will. If God is
love, okay? And he loves people, then he
must trust people. Therefore, freedom
freedom of will is the most important
principle. Okay? Same thing if you're a
parent. If you truly love your child,
you will let your child go and make his
own mistakes. You will not protect your
child. Okay? Even if it means that your
child goes to the park and might get
kidnapped or whatever, okay? You have to
let him go. You have to let him or her
go because true love means trusting
other people. Okay,
keep on going.
You say what I have heard is clear to me
but this is hidden from me. Why God weld
precisely this pathway for redemption?
>> Okay. So again the Catholic Church
teaches you that Jesus redeemed us from
our for redeemed us from our sins. Okay.
But then the question is why did you
have to kill himself again? That makes
no sense. Keep on going
>> brother. This ordinance is buried from
the eyes of everyone whose intellect has
not ma matured within the flame of love.
>> So Peter is saying to Dante, yes I know
this makes makes no sense because you're
thinking with your mind but the mind is
not where the spark is. Okay. The divine
spark is in the heart. So stop thinking
with your mind and feel with your heart
and let the spark the divine spark glow
in you and then you will see the truth
for yourself.
>> Sorry. Okay.
>> The godly godness that has banished
every envy from its own self burn in
itself and sparkling soul. It shows
eternal beauties. All that derives
directly from this godness is
everlasting. Since the sale of godness
impressed an imprint that ever alters.
>> Okay. So God is perfect. He's forever
good. He's forever love. He's forever
compassion, forever forgiveness. Okay.
And there's there's a spark of God in
us, right? The divine spark which is our
hearts. So there's always a this
perfection in us. Okay.
Keep on going. Only man sing annoys
man's liberty makes him unlike the
highest good. So that in him the
brightness of its light is dimin.
>> Okay this is important. Okay. Even
though the spark is forever in us we can
cover it up with mud. We can cover it up
with dirt. We can forget about it. Okay.
Why? How? By doing evil. By disobeying.
All right. If we do more and more evil,
we forget the spark more and more and it
it dims in us. So the spark can glow or
it can dim depending on our actions but
the spark will ever always be there.
>> So if like [snorts] you said that
parents the true love is to trust right?
So if parents trust their kid they will
let their kids to make mistakes. But
what if kids are for example being
kidnapped and they're being killed? Is
that still count as the love of trust?
Okay, obviously if your child is in
danger, you go save your child. Okay,
but you cannot let your fear and anxiety
of your child being kidnapped
destroy the child's freedom. Does that
make sense? You cannot impose your fear
on your child.
>> Like you need to let your child to feel
the anxieties.
>> No, no, no, no, no. You have to let your
child do what your child wants to do.
your child wants to go play in the go
play in the playground, you let the
child go play in the playground. Okay?
And if you feel like there's a danger,
then you go and make sure that your
child is safe. You understand?
>> But still doing but still letting him to
do what they want.
>> Yeah. Okay. Look, when you when you're
actually a parent, you know what is safe
and what is not safe. Okay? Sending your
child to the playground where there are
other children, there are adults
around is safe. Do you understand?
Sending your child outside at midnight
to one of the streets is not safe. Do
you understand?
>> Okay. You know, you don't have to think
about this.
All right.
Okay. Keep on reading.
>> And man cannot regain his dignity unless
within left emptiness man fills a void
with just a mans for evil pleasure.
>> Okay. So the problem is this. We
do all this evil and now we can't
forgive ourselves. So we're stuck where
we are. Okay? We cannot compensate for
the evil that that we do. So what we do
is do more evil to ignore the fact that
we cannot forgive ourselves. Does that
make sense? So evil creates more evil.
Evil compounds on evil. So now we're
just stuck. Okay. So the first so by
disobeying God by eating that that fruit
by trying to be like God we created evil
and this evil forces us to be more evil
now we're just stuck. Okay
for when your nature sings so totally
within its seed then from these
dignities just as from paradise that
nature parted.
>> Okay. So we left the garden of Eden not
because we broke the law. We left the
garden of Eden because
we cannot forgive ourselves from the
evil that we've committed and so we keep
on doing more and more evil. Okay. So
the garden of Eden is metaphorical. Keep
on going. And they can never be regained
if you consider carefully. By any way
that did not pass across one of these fs
either through nothing other than his
mercy. God has to pardon man or of
himself. Man has to prefer payment for
his folly. Okay. So now that we've
broken the law, now that we've disobeyed
God, now that we've there's evil in our
hearts, how what can we do? Okay. And
what Beatric says is there's two
possibilities. The first possibility is
that we compensate for the first evil
for the first act of disobedience. And
what Petric says is you can't do that
because you try to be God. You try to
kill God. So you cannot ever compensate
God for the evil that you've done. Okay?
And then she says, "Well, the other
possibility is that God forgives you."
The problem though is that if God just
forgives you, you won't learn anything.
Okay,
you want to go. Man in his limits could
not recmp recompense
for no obedience, no humility he offered
later could have been so deep that it
could match the heights he made to reach
through disobedience. Man lacked the
power to offer satisfaction by himself.
>> Okay. Good. Okay. So, do you understand
this idea? Okay. You try to be God. So,
you can't ever ask for forgiveness for
that. Keep on going.
>> For God show greater generosity in
giving his own self that man might be
able to rise than if he simply pardoned.
For every other means fell short of
justice except the way whereby the son
of God humbled himself where he became
incar incarnate.
>> Okay. Incarnate just means human. Okay.
So this is why Jesus had to kill
himself. All right. So the problem is
that God has to forgive us. But he has
to forgive forgive us in a way that
allows us to learn from our mistakes and
be better people. Okay? And so let's
let's use an analogy. The analogy is
this. Um I'm a father and I have a
daughter named Eve. And I have a dog.
And I say to Eve, "I love you, Eve, so
much." And then Eve says to me, "Do you
love me or do you love the dog more?" I
said, "I love you both equally. Love is
infinite." Of course, I love you, but I
also love the dog. And Eve goes and says
to herself, "Yeah, but how do I know he
truly loves me?" So what Eve does is she
kills the dog. Okay. And then Eve, Eve
says to me, "Hey, do you love me or do
you love the dog more?" And now I'm kind
of stuck the father, right? Because if I
punish her, that shows her I love the
dog more, right? But if I don't punish
her, she's going to do this again. Okay?
She's going to kill kill another animal.
So I'm stuck. So what do I do? So what
God decides to do is this. The only way
out of this conundrum, the only way out
of this paradox is if I punish myself.
Okay? Because I should have said to her,
I love you as much as the dog. All
right? So what I do is I take a whip and
I hit myself. All right? And Eve watches
this. And now Eve knows, first of all, I
do love her because I'm punishing myself
for her sake. And second of all, she
won't do it again because she doesn't
want to see me punished. And that's why
Jesus had to kill himself. Do you
understand? That's the logic here. Now
it makes sense, right? God had to punish
himself so that we would be humbled by a
sacrifice. We would feel so much reg
remorse and regret for making God die
that we would never ever disobey him
again. We would never ever try to become
God ourselves. And that's why
this had to happen. Okay? And because of
this, Jesus freed us from the evil in us
and led us to the path of good. Because
now all we have to do is remember Jesus,
remember what he said, remember what he
taught and we ever forever will forever
be on the path towards the light. Yes.
>> Uh do we like for example if I had done
a extreme mistakes in previously do I
can I completely make it up or just uh
forgive myself because I think I can't.
>> Okay, that that that's a great point.
Okay, so yeah, so the problem is this.
The problem is that there are people who
do real evil in this world. Okay, it's
possible like a man kills your daughter
uh and then he's put in prison for the
longest time and it's he does all this
evil and so can he be forgiven? And the
answer is yes. Because the only way for
this world to work is if people are
allowed to be forgiven. If people are
not allowed to be forgiven, this entire
world, this entire universe breaks down.
That's why God is a God of forgiveness.
Okay? Because if you think about it, if
you think, okay, if we don't have
forgiveness, what world do we live in?
We live in a world of vengeance, right?
If you kill my daughter, then I have to
have to go kill your daughter and then
you're going to have to go kill my
family and I have to go kill your
family. Okay? So, the only way for this
world to work, the only way for just to
prevail is if we're allowed to forgive
each other. And previously we don't have
a tool to forgive each other because we
ourselves don't have the wisdom. And now
with the arrival of Jesus, we remember
that if Jesus forgive us, Jesus will
forgive me always. And so if I turn
towards Jesus, then I will be forgiven.
But like currently I think I still could
not forgive myself for making that
mistake. Like I think whatever things
that I do to make make up the mistake I
think I could not forgive me at that
time making that mistake
>> right but at the same time you went to
prison right you you've been punished
already so justice hasn't served so you
can now forgive yourself okay just
because you've you uh believe in Jesus
doesn't mean you won't go to prison for
killing someone you're still going to go
to prison but now you can forgive
yourself because you've done your time
And also because you remember that Jesus
Jesus forgives you. Okay? But the only
way for you to move on in your life, the
only way for society to move on is if
you're able to forgive yourself. Okay?
That doesn't make sense. If in a world
there's no forgiveness, this world would
break down really quickly because
everyone would just kill each other.
Okay? So, and again, what what's
happening is this, and this is what
Dante teaches us. You're thinking of
your head. Okay? because you're still
young. When you grow older and your
heart matures and you have more life
experience, then you'll be able to feel
your heart. Once you feel your heart,
all this will make sense to you. Okay?
But but but I completely understand
where you're coming from because at your
age, if someone told me this, I'd be
like, you're crazy. This makes no sense
because if you do evil, then you should
be then your entire life should be one
of evil. If you do evil, evil should
come to you. Okay. But what Jesus is
saying is is like no no in that world no
one can be happy. Okay. Because the
people whose evil has been done to them
are so focused on vengeance, on hatred,
on anger
that you can never ever be a happy
person. Okay? You leave the monad. You
leave the divine. Okay? So when you hate
someone, you're actually hitting
yourself as opposed to that person.
Okay. All right. So now that we
understand the
uh this idea, now what Don is gonna
explain is why are we here? Okay. What's
the purpose of the universe? Okay. Can
you read uh Alan? You say, I see that
water, see the fire and air and earth
and all that they compose harm to the
corruption and endure so briefly. And
yet these two were things created. If
what has been said above is true, then
these things never should be subject to
corruption.
>> Okay? So the idea is like God is
perfect. Everything he creates is
perfect. So if that's the case, then why
do we die? And so what Peter says is
this. God is perfect. He creates
perfection. But he creates the laws of
the universe. He creates the game. Okay?
That's perfect. The things within the
game
enter a cycle of destruction and life.
Life and death. Okay, because that's the
only way for the game for the universe
to work properly. Okay, does that make
sense? Okay, keep on reading.
>> Brother, the angels and the pure country
where you are now, these may be said to
be created and they are in all their
being. Whereas the elements that you
have mentioned, as well as those things
that are made from them, receive their
form from a created power.
The matter they contain has been created
just as within the stars that well about
them. The power to give form had been
created. The race and motion of the holy
light draw forth the soul of every
animal and plant from matter able to
take form.
>> Okay. So understand the world the laws
of the universe are created. Okay. But
your life is breathed forth immediately
by the chief god good who so enormous
enamemers it of his own self that it
desires him always. So reasoning you
also can deduce your resurrection. You
need but remember the way in which your
human flesh was fashioned when both of
the first parents were created.
>> Okay. So the world that we live in is a
world in which we can make mistakes in
which we can learn, we can grow. Okay.
And we don't have to worry about making
mistakes because when we die, all that
will happen is we'll just return to the
good and we will be reincarnated. Okay.
We'll come back. Jesus was resurrected.
But so but we will be resurrected as
well. We have infinite opportunity to
grow as souls and that's the purpose of
life to learn to make mistakes to be
creative to imagine new possibilities.
That's why we were created. Okay? And to
ensure that we can continue to grow,
there's death. Okay? Death allows for a
reset. Death allows us to rejuvenate
ourselves and learn from mistakes.
So don't think about this lifetime.
Think about all possible lifetimes and
live your life accordingly to that.
Okay? Make the most of your life here by
making as many mistakes as possible
because only by making mistakes can you
actually grow as a soul. Okay?
All right.
So, this is uh Leon Leonardo da Vinci's
famous painting, the last supper. Now,
this depicts Jesus before his uh
betrayal, before he is crucified by the
Romans. Okay. What's really interesting
about this painting is you can see
there's there's a number here, right? 33
1 33. When you go to the Bible and you
look for the passage
in Lamentations, you have this
quotation.
For no one is cast off by the Lord
forever through he brings grief, he will
show compassion. So great is his
unfolding love. for it does not willing
willingly bring affle affliction or
grief to anyone.
>> Okay, that's who Jesus is. Okay, Jesus
came to remind us that
we will all be forgiven in the end. So,
forgive other people. Okay, love your
enemy.
All right. Okay. So, um let's look at
what actually the Bible says. Okay. So,
this is what Jesus taught. And again um
I believe this is what Jesus taught
because one
gospel of Thomas is a unique voice.
Remember the thing about poetry is that
it is unique. It is divine spark itself.
So it cannot be replicated. Okay. So
when we read the gospel Thomas you can
see this is poetic. This is beautiful
and it touches you. It's a divine spark.
That's number one. Number two is what he
teaches aligns with every other poor
prophet that that that we've studied so
far, right? Number three is these other
poor prophets like Dante, Dashki, they
they go back and they're able to see
exactly what Jesus was teaching us.
Okay? So that's why I'm convinced that
the gospel of Thomas
um is the true teachings of Jesus. There
are also other teachings of Jesus that
we find in the Bible that also conforms
to our theory. Okay. So this is from the
gospel of Matthew and this is called the
uh sermon on the mount where Jesus
stands on a hill and he's preaching the
secrets of the universe to people. Okay.
So can you read please Alan?
>> Yeah. Blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs is the kingdom of heaven. Blessed
are those who mourn for they will be
comforted. Blessed are the meek, for
they will inherit the earth. Blessed are
those who hunger this and thirst for
righteousness, for they will be filled.
Blessed are the mer merciful, for they
will be shown mercy. Blessed are the
pure in heart, for they will see God.
Blessed are the peacemakers, for they
will be called children of God. Blessed
are those who are pre persecuted because
of righteousness. of theirs is the
kingdom of heaven.
>> So this is his message to people, right?
What matters is the spark inside of you.
It doesn't matter how wealthy you are.
It doesn't matter how powerful you are.
In fact, it is probably those who are
slaves that will benefit who who are
more virtuous and as such they will
inherit the kingdom. Okay, keep on
reading.
>> You are the salt of earth. But if the
salt loses its saintness, saintness, how
can can it be made salty again? It is no
longer good for anything except to be
thrown out and tramped underfoot. You
are the light of the world. A tongue
built on a hill cannot be hidden.
Neither do people light a lamp and put
it under a bowl. Instead, they put it on
its stand. And it gives light to
everyone in the house. In the same way,
let light shine before others. that they
may see you good deeds and glorify you
father in heaven.
>> Okay. So be the light. Okay. Every one
of you has a light [clears throat] in
you. Every one of you has a power to
change the universe. Every one of you
has a power to do good in this world.
Okay. Keep on going. You have heard that
it was said, "Love your neighbor and
hate your enemy." But I tell you, love
your enemy and pray for those who
persecute you that you may be children
of your father in heaven. He causes his
son to rise on the evil and the goods
and sends rain on the righteous and
unrighteous. If you love those who love
you, what reward will you get? Are not
even the tax collectors doing that? And
if you great only your own people, what
are you doing more than others? Do not
even p pack pagans do that. Be perfect
therefore as your heavenly father is
perfect.
>> Okay, we are in this world to do as much
good as possible. Thank evil people
because it opp gives you opportunity to
do good. Okay, there's no evil in the
world. How do you possibly do good?
Right?
Keep on going. Do not store up for
yourself treasures on earth where mouth
moth and vermin destroy and where
thieves break in and steal, but store up
for yourself treasures in heaven where
moth and vermin do not destroy. And
where thieves do not break in and steal.
For where your treasure is, there your
heart will be also. Okay? So focus on
your own spiritual enlightenment. Focus
on making your heart pure, good, and
virtuous. Don't worry about other
people. Don't worry about money and
these things because when you die, you
can't take these things with you. But
your heart will always follow you
wherever you are. Okay, keep on going.
>> The eye is a lamp of the body. If your
eyes are healthy, your whole body will
be full of light. But if your eye are
unhealthy, your whole body will be full
of darkness. If then the light within
you is darkness, how great is that
darkness?
>> Okay, so this is really important idea.
Okay. But we imagine reality. So what
matters is how you imagine this reality.
What matters is how you see the world.
Okay. And how you see the world is a
reflection of the spark inside of you.
If you see goodness, if you do goodness,
the then goodness will come. Okay. This
also called um the law of attraction.
Okay. Keep on going. No one can serve
two masters. Either you will hate the
one and love the other or you will be
devoted to the one and dis despise the
other. You cannot serve both God and
money.
>> Okay, this this is a really important
idea. What is Satan? Satan is money.
It's power.
Okay, so this world belongs to Satan.
This rule, this world is ruled by Satan.
There's nothing you can do about it.
When you leave that world is the world
of God. Okay, so it's your choice. Okay,
your choice is to triumph in this world
or to triumph in the spiritual world.
It's your choice. But you cannot have
both, guys. Okay, you can either you can
be Alan Musk. You can you can have all
this wealth in this world, but we'll see
what happens to Ellen Musk, you know,
after he dies. So, he won't die. Okay.
So, his plan is I won't die, then I'm
good.
Okay. All right. Um,
keep keep on going.
>> Not everyone who says to me, Lord, Lord,
will enter the kingdom of heaven, but
only the one who does the will of my
father who is in heaven. Many will say
to me on that day, Lord, Lord, did we
not prophecy in your name, and in your
name drive out demons, and in your name
perform many miracles? Then I will tell
them plainly, I never knew you. Away
from me, your evadors. Okay, so this is
a really important idea. The Christian
religion tells us that you must believe
in Jesus to be saved by Jesus. All that
matters is believe in Jesus. Doesn't
matter what you do. Doesn't matter what
you say. What matters is your belief in
Jesus. And what Jesus himself is telling
us, no, no, no. Don't use my name. Okay?
Don't follow me. Follow your heart. In
fact, if you use my name, it's because
you mean to do evil in this world.
So the question then is how do we get
from this to the Catholic Church, which
is no, you must obey us otherwise you'll
be condemned to hell. Okay? And that's
the topic we'll discuss next class. How
the Catholic Church was created. And the
argument I will make to you is it was
created by the Roman Empire.
Okay. And not Jesus himself. Okay. So
any questions guys? Yeah.
>> I think like you said that people have
infinite lives and like death is a reset
of your life and you can learn many
times but I think death will just clear
a person's memory and they won't
remember the mistakes and the things
that they learn.
>> Yeah that's a great point. Okay. Yes.
Exactly. So the idea is the divine spark
right so the divine spark either glows
brightly or it dims. So when you die,
what goes is not the brain. You won't
remember anything, the memories, but
what goes is the is the spark. Do you
understand? The spark if it glows really
brightly, it goes up to a higher plane.
You're closer to the monad. You're
closer to God. And therefore, you feel
more pleasure,
right? But if your spark has been dim,
it goes to a lower place.
And so what you want to do is obviously
glow that um spark as much as possible.
All right? And and so again, um I know
this is hard to understand, but most
people will not figure this out. Okay?
You understand? It may it may take take
like 50 lifetimes before you figure out,
you know what, I should really try to
glow my my spark. It may take a thousand
lifetimes, a million lifetimes, who
knows? But it's your choice. Do you
understand? some will figure out quick
more quicker than others.
Okay, so this this this is the thing
that you must remember. Every religion
teaches teaches teaches us like when you
die, you won't you won't remember how
much money you have. You won't remember
anything. Okay, but what will what you
what you but what you will uh remember
what you will leave behind is the amount
of goodness you did or the amount of
evil you did. Okay, does that make
sense? Okay, any more questions, guys?
Okay, great. So, next class we do the
rise of the Catholic Church.